President Trump wants Americans to take
an existing drug to fight coronavirus
but as Ben Tracy reports his advice
contradicts dr. Anthony foul she and
other top scientists who say we simply
don't know if it's the right medicine we
don't have time we don't have two hours
because there are people dying right now
in the last minute news conference
Sunday night to President Trump repeated
that doctor should use the drug
hydroxychloroquine which is not yet
proven to treat coronavirus they should
do it what really do we have to lose dr.
Anthony Fauci has called the drugs
effectiveness anecdotal I don't think we
could definitively say it works over the
weekend found reportedly clash with the
president's economic advisor Peter
Navarro who said the drug works the
president stepped in when found she was
asked about the drug at the briefing the
president says the federal government
has now stockpiled 29 million doses of
the drug what do I know I'm not a doctor
I'm not a doctor but I have common sense
mr. Trump also dismissed questions about
a report that the u.s. waited two months
after the corona virus outbreak was
obvious in China to stock up on critical
medical supplies FEMA the military what
they've done is a miracle meanwhile the
former captain of the nuclear aircraft
carrier Theodore Roosevelt which is
suffering a corona virus outbreak has
now reportedly tested positive in his
importantin on Guam captain Brett
Crozier was fired by the Navy after a
letter he wrote to Navy leaders about
the situation on his ship was leaked to
the media he was given a hero's goodbye
from his crew but a vote of
no-confidence from the Secretary of
Defense the Navy as a culture of swiftly
and decisively removing captains if they
lose confidence in them the Secretary of
Defense says he is now advising that old
military personnel worldwide wear cloth
face masks President Trump was asked
again yesterday here at the White House
if he plans to wear one and he said I
would if I thought it was important Gail
then thank you very much